There's always been something a little off
about Thanos and his quest for galactic domination,
and it has nothing to do with how much he
likes sitting down.
It's all about the Infinity Gauntlet, the
artifact that Thanos will apparently wield
in Avengers: Infinity War, and the strange
fact that there seems to be more than one
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
"I only ask that you take this matter seriously."
We first got a glimpse of the Infinity Gauntlet,
which is specifically constructed to hold
the powerful Infinity Stones, in the background
of Odin's trophy room in 2011's Thor.
In that scene, the gauntlet held the Infinity
Stones and was made for a right hand, which
is a subtly significant detail.
The next time we saw the Gauntlet was during
a mid-credits scene after 2015's Avengers:
Age of Ultron.
Thanos reached into a vault, put on a glove
with no stones on it and held it up.
It looked to be on the left hand this time.
"Illusion?"
"No, this is real."
But questions still lingered about his possession
of the artifact, like how could Thanos get
the Gauntlet when it's supposed to be safely
stowed away on Asgard?
And aren't the Infinity Stones supposed to
be scattered around the universe anyway?
Two years ago, Marvel's Kevin Feige told CinemaBlend
there's a simple explanation, saying,
"There are two different gloves.
That was not Odin's vault that you see at
the end [of Age of Ultron]."
"Alright!"
That sounds simple enough, but not everyone
read that interview, and besides, Marvel's
not always known for being so forthright.
However, Thor: Ragnarok has now proven that,
indeed, Feige was telling the truth.
In the film, we see Hela storm Odin's castle
and walk around his trophy room to reveal
that lots of the trophies are actually fake,
including the first-seen Infinity Gauntlet,
which she unceremoniously knocks over.
Soooo, that solves that.
Now the stage is set for Infinity War, and
Feige's backstory checks out.
There are two gloves, Thanos has one of them,
and he might just make good on that promise
after all.
"And I will bathe star ways in your blood."
Now we just have to wait to find out if Thanos
has got the real deal and whether and how
he'll put his Infinity Gauntlet to use when
the Avengers: Infinity War hits theaters on
April 25th, 2018.
"I'm gonna miss these little talks of ours."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!